hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren command
vorstellung ich weiß dass heute montag
ist und eigentlich habe ich freitag als
minecraft tag nur ich habe ja damals mal
gesagt freitags kommt immer minecraft
und unter der woche
doch ab und zu minecraft kommen deswegen
habe ich mir oben schon sonnenberg
gesucht wo außerordentlich viele
schweine da was macht diese kurier
du kannst dich zu den schweinen hier ich
hab halt einfach einen coolen neuen
command gefunden und den zeige ich euch
jetzt auch einfach mal wir geben wieder
ein / gfp command unterstrich block um
den command blog zu erhalten gehen in
den redstone tab und holen uns einen
lämmer der command ist jetzt hier drin
wir drücken einfach mal auf dann lassen
das ganze hier aufbaut und bevor sich
das hier aufbaut muss ich euch noch
sagen es ist wie immer das video zu aus
ist aufgebaut das video zu dem command
der urheber und einen link zu dem
command selbst ist in der beschreibung
vorhanden der command ist recht simpel
und recht klein und fügt tatsächlich
nicht allzu viel hinzu allerdings ist es
eine sache wo ich finde dass die
unbedingt weitergeführt werden sollte
ich habe vor einem jahr oder länger habe
ich mal ein video gemacht was die
internet muttis das zeige ich euch mal
hier da könnt ihr draufklicken da könnt
ihr das video sehen und da ging es darum
dass das internet in minecraft war da
war dann quasi so ein bildschirm mit
internet unter
und dann kommt man da halt auch
verschiedene webseiten draufgehen und
hier ist das ganze jetzt als command
quasi dargestellt worden
das ganze ist von der red engineer und
er hat halt 50.000 abonnenten erreicht
was erst mal das essen applaus wert
unseren 50.000 abonnenten special war
dann halt dieser command da könnt ihr
einfach mal hier auf den screen druck
und wir sehen schon youtube in minecraft
diese kuh ist glaube ich auch recht
was will die hier was will diese schwein
hier die beiden sind sehr fasziniert
davon
könnt ihr mal gehen jedenfalls hat der
red engine ihr halt 50.000 abonnenten
erreicht das leder vor noch schon
eingeblendet und hat deswegen diesem
command erstellt der hier sogar
angezeigt wird minecraft youtube.com
adblock 50,5 die fersen
ja wir können jetzt hier einfach mal
richtig drauf machen und dann sehen wir
schon jetzt schnell gerade irgendwie
gleich in die magic trick und jetzt
können wir hier draufklicken dann haben
wir so einen like-button und den können
wir jetzt nämlich hier einschmelzen und
dann seht ihr schon bekommen wir einen
magic cache der die sachen hat zu 100
prozent gesundheit werden auf 100
prozent wolle und 400 prozent bei 6 100
prozent bei 100 prozent männer und 100
prozent und das ist jetzt von diesem
kuchen den der uns gegeben hat und das
ist allerdings noch nicht alles
der ist weg so sieht das ganze hier dann
von innen aus da haben wir die schrift
und die ist dann auch hier und dann um
wieso bist denn du immer noch hier was
wir auch machen können es uns hier einen
ende bzw einen amboss holen und wie ich
hole mir jetzt auch einfach mal ein
steak papier dann setzte nämlich den
endl einfach mal hierhin packen das
papier da rein und das papier können wir
first nennen dabei ist es allerdings
wichtig dass ihr alles klein schreibt
diese kuh fakt nicht übel aber ich habe
jetzt hier 64 papiere die first heißen
und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise das
video einfach noch mal
ach komm ich kann einfach draufklicken
dann spielt sich noch mal ab wenn ich
jetzt so ein zettel da reinschmeißen mit
first schon bekomme ich einen coockie
also försters kuckuck kuckuck soll als
ein bisschen so dieses sein das auf
youtube jeder immer wenn er der erste
bei dem video schreibt der erste oder
fährst oder irgendwie so ein scheiß
unterkam es halt irgendwann dann so dass
dieses putin mihm so gemacht wurde mit
gibt eine kuh keith richards du hast den
ersten kommentaren in diesem keks diese
kuh da unten ist einfach die ist doch
michelle
ich kann dieses spiel jetzt wieder
ausmachen und dann wieder an machen dann
kann ich das video wieder von vorne
spielen dann schmeißt er beispielsweise
mal wieder hier so ein ding rein wenn
der red dann gleich da es genau da und
jetzt bekomme ich hier die cookies
decken sich hoch wie sonst als bissig
keine blätter mehr aber kriege ich ihr
die ganze zeit kubica ist doch unfassbar
ich hab keine blätter mehr und wenn ich
das video hat maike und den leica
reinschmeißen bekommen ich diesen magic
das ist quasi alles ihr sagt euch jetzt
bestimmt wo kann man da auf andere
webseiten gehen kann man irgendwas
machen
da geht nichts außer einer kuh mama ist
die komplett bescheuert
ich weiß das ist jetzt eigentlich kein
command ich hätte vorstellen müssen weil
es halt quasi nur seinen kanal ist aber
ich wollte erstmal sagen alles gut
50.000 abonnenten der red engineered ich
denke wir haben dabei auch so ein
bisschen mitgeholfen dadurch das
filmpaar commands von dem angenommen hat
und jeder so süße also immer dann
wirklich auf die kanäle von den leuten
gegangen seid und dann noch mal die
videos angeschaut haben und den leuten
gesagt habe chilliger command und so
dass des übels ich hab euch alles was zu
einer beschreibung verlinkt ihr könnt
ihr einfach mal auf seinen kanal gehen
und ihm alles gute zu 50.000 abonnenten
von crafter wünschen
ich glaube sogar erst ein deutscher und
wir müssen ihm unbedingt schreiben dass
er das weitermachen soll ich will dass
das ist das wäre so geil wenn du quasi
irgendwann in einer map drin hast du
musst einfach ein command eingeben dann
hast du komplett youtube in minecraft
drin das ist stelle ich mir unglaublich
cool vor natürlich könnte ich auch
google chrome eben einfach auf youtube
gehen aber das ist genauso cool wie wenn
in minecraft auf einmal agrio
funktioniert oder in minecraft cod oder
so wenn in minecraft hier wirklich
internet funktioniert und alles mögliche
komplett fände ich es einfach geil ich
würde sagen das war's mit dem heutigen
video wenn es euch gefallen hat und ich
öfters solche bisschen innovativere und
bessere modifikationen bzw mods
vorstellen soll dann zeigt es mir mit
einer bewertung und an alle die meinen
kanal schon länger beobachten
jetzt kommt der adventskalender freunde
ich bin derzeit ein bisschen im four
produzieren weil ich bald im skiurlaub
bin deswegen in dem video morgen mache
ich für 14 auf und da mache ich heute
einfach nur 15 auf also seid da nicht
irritiert hintertür 15
ist ein kalender hintertür 15 war dieses
kleid hier das hänge ich einfach mal
wieder an unseren tollen kleiderständer
hier ich habe übrigens mal aufnahme zum
ein bisschen gepimpt und mir so ikea
boxen hier unten geholt und dann habe
ich das ja auch mal so ein bisschen
umgeräumt und das sieht jetzt alles ein
bisschen ordentlicher tatsächlich aus
aber ich würde sagen euch das video
gefallen an zeigt mir was macht diese
schwein länder vorne jetzt wir sehen uns
läuft noch